yeah no if now this is the theory this
is the big this is the big part if you
can make other people good at their jobs
not just you good at your job but if you
can lead other people and set them up
for success and make other people good
at their job
you are the 10xer you're the 10xer
[Music]
welcome to my first million thanks for
joining me Sam
all right so Sean is in California
there's a power outage last minute I
called Nick Huber we're going to give
you uh like the proper introduction but
basically
um you were on a month ago six weeks ago
and it was one month I think it was the
second most downloaded pod in the last
90 days it had something like 150 or
even more downloads something like that
so the people loved you and uh what what
was your introduction last time Nick has
uh at least 100 million dollars in
storage units of which I am an investor
in so I always disclose that and you
also own three or four different
companies right now that are doing
really well or own part of yep yep
dabbling and dabbling in a lot of stuff
you texted me actually one hour and six
minutes ago and you said hey can you
come on the pod in one hour
and I said yes and you said do you
actually have good content and I said
yes I'm a Content machine I was just
kidding with you and you said hey you
need to make a document and send it to
me are you sure you have the fire
you put the pressure on me
because we don't ever I never asked the
same person twice but I know that you're
easy to work with and let's do that I
knew you'd show up in time well you blew
up you blew up my life man I mean I I
looked back you you brought me on the
show the very first time on November 11
2020. and then another time February 16
2023 which was four weeks ago today
and honestly it blew up my world I mean
I'm telling you really what are the
results
I mean support Shepard the company that
I use to hire a lot of you know va's and
and I'm a partner in 200 plus leads of
people business owners who reached out
for the first time to hire their first
VA which is freaking awesome and that's
like four grand a month or something or
two grand a month it just costs about
three grand it's 30 of the first year
salary 35 the first year salary to make
the placement so average tickets between
three and four grand
um all the other businesses too that I
mentioned on there got some leads I'm
Ari cost sag webrun.com
uh it's just crazy man got reached out
to by a lot of people and actually have
have kind of got started with a couple
more businesses since then so it's just
been wild so I uh like I went to
Vancouver and I was hanging out with
some guys that were like worth hundreds
of millions and maybe one or two of them
in the billionaire range and we are
having dinner and they would stop
talking about that episode and they
wouldn't stop talking about you and they
were like I gotta meet Nick I introduced
you to one of them
um and uh Courtney and um
but they wouldn't stop talking about you
and I was like damn people love Nick
it's amazing it's been amazing I think
the the network effects of that have
really impacted my life and man I have
you to think in a major way so really
really appreciate it we were at a I did
like a MFM Meetup last night Jonathan
organized it and we had uh 500 people
RSVP I don't know how many people showed
up but it was awesome we got to like
meet people and uh a lot of people were
asking about you and uh it was really
fun to get out from behind the
microphone because what people I always
say this I said this last night what
they don't realize is like
Sean and I at least we talked throughout
the week but we try to save our if we
ever if we're ever talking about
something juicy he'll just say like
don't don't tell me tell me when we're
live and right now I'm just in my I turn
like a small bedroom into a little it
just has his desk and a camera and you
probably it looks like you're in the
same you have like a small office in
your house and like they don't realize
that like we're just a bunch of like
doofuses behind a mic just barely I mean
we prepare but like we're just kind of
like having a conversation with our
friends and it's really cool to like see
the people and like actually hear from
them and so we did that last night it
was exhausting but I was very happy to
do it and so hopefully you you've been
able to meet some of the people as well
it's crazy because we can sit here and
talk and I'm a little bit nervous just
because I know the impact of my first
million I know that 100 000 people might
listen to this but imagine how nervous
we would be if we were sitting in two
chairs in the middle of Dallas Cowboys
Stadium with a hundred thousand people
watching I mean it would be a lot more
real it would make it feel a lot more
real
we've had so many people say uh why
don't you guys do it in real life like
you and Sean like one and I'm like well
it's just more convenient but also
it's like one time I recorded at a
studio and there was like this like lady
at the uh at like the sound board and
she was like hip and cool looking and
was like a cute lady and I remember
she wouldn't laugh every once in a while
when I thought I said something funny
and I got in my head I was like [__] I
didn't I didn't was that douchey was
that lame and then everyone and then
when she would laugh I'd be like all
right I got her I got her I gotta keep
going and so like she was my audience
and I remember I was like changing
everything I did and afterwards I was
like Ben I can't do this with with Eddie
these people in this room anymore it's
getting in my head I'm trying to impress
him too much it's tough man it's tough
I'm having a live event on the 22nd in
Athens um which you guys inspired me to
do I put it together right after that
and 30 people have bought tickets to it
so I'm a little bit bummed out but we're
gonna actually go through it's next
Wednesday night in Athens we're gonna
actually have it see how many people
show up and see if it's a success but
yeah when you put yourself out for a
live event it comes with a new level of
Stress and Anxiety for sure so I moved
to San Francisco in 2012. I moved out
there and I moved out there from
Tennessee and I I'm still a little rough
back then I was really rough around the
edges and this was right uh yeah and
this and this was like basically I moved
out there
and like P I would wear jeans and like
boots and a white T-shirt all the time
and people and I had a little bit of a
twang
you know and people would kind of tease
me and I told them from Tennessee and
they're like
you know what do you date your cousin
like they would make fun of me and I
felt really like jealous of the Stanford
kids I would like I remember I took a
bus or a train out and to walk around
Stanford's campus I thought it was like
good a Goodwill Hunting moment I was
like dude am I gonna meet all these
Geniuses what's gonna happen and I got
so envious and so I created this thing
called the anti-mba because I was
envious that I didn't get my MBA from
Stanford because I would meet all these
kids and they had this like awesome
Network and so I created this book club
and we would meet once a week we would
read one book a month
and we would meet once a week and go
over the trailing like you know weeks
reading and then I would call in a guest
to like lead the discussion and I would
talk to them and I posted an ad on
Craigslist that's how I got my first
people and so cieva one of my best
friends sieva
um who's like a big entrepreneur he was
one of those people you know he's one of
my closest friends so I met him that way
and so I would host these book groups
and we it would be 10 people at first
and then the next time like 12 and then
over time I did this for a year every
week for a year I got like 3 000 people
signed up to my email list then I hosted
an event uh that was uh like maybe 80
people came and then I hosted hustlecon
and 300 people came but
it was very slow like these like events
I do very like it was like a four year
grind and then at hustlecon eventually
we got like 2 500 people coming and so
like these events and and then Sean and
I did a live pod in Miami and like maybe
a hundred people came and it wasn't that
good and then we did it again and it was
a little bit better so like these events
it takes time and it's hard and it's
hard because unlike the internet when
you you know with the internet you can
delete some stuff with an event
you just are going to embarrass yourself
you know what I mean it's so it is
challenging but it was like a grind to
do do those events and getting getting
people to actually show up is tough I
mean to get people to listen to my first
million or my podcast the Nick Huber
show all they got to do is flip through
flip through podcast click a little
button if they don't like it they're
gone getting somebody to buy a ticket
drive somewhere the uncomfort of meeting
other people you know it's more
difficult
where do you want to go today what do
you want to drive so I want to talk
about
the traits of a successful entrepreneur
what made what makes a whether it's a
partner an operator a manager at a
company and when I say entrepreneur I
don't necessarily just mean somebody who
starts a business I mean somebody who
leads other people inside of an
organization what makes those people
really really good at what they do
and I think you have a lot of experience
tracking down and identifying these
people who are killers we'll call them
10xers they're the people who you know I
have a theory that 80 of of workers are
just kind of skating by and maybe
they're adding a little bit of value to
a company but the top 20 percent are
generating outsized return for the
company that they work for or themselves
if they're an entrepreneur what makes
those people tick I'll talk about that
all right the most interesting thing
part about this is that it's kind of
this will morph into
a tactical guide of literally starting a
company because when you start to
identify these things and you track down
these people and you bring them together
a company is nothing more than just a
group of people that all work together
so if you can find these people and put
them together which I know you can which
I'm confident that I can and anybody who
scales a business can do
um you can you can make a lot of money
fast so let's dig in well when I when I
first started my career it was basically
just can I make enough money to pay for
my own bills and then once you get past
that point maybe that point is it's
different for everyone for us it was in
the thirty thousand dollar a month range
once we got to thirty thousand dollars a
month I realized cool it's sustainable
to a certain level I need to hire people
and I hired one or two people in a few
of my different companies where once we
got to like 30 and 40 000 a month when
you hire the right person it can 10x
fairly quickly and at that thirty
thousand Mark I realized at a young age
I am in the collection of people
business I just have to collect
interesting people and you have to play
like a long-term game because it doesn't
you can't they're not always available
but if you like play the long game
relationships last a long time so I've
done a good job of collecting people and
I you asked me this so I made a list
um so uh four traits that I always look
for the first is I look for emotional
only stable people the reason I look for
that is I'm not exactly the most
emotionally stable person I'm the fire
so when when it comes to starting stuff
I don't need anyone to motivate me I'm
the flame I'll get it started I don't
need any gasoline I don't need anything
of that like that but I need people who
can
when you're the type of person like me
and you have really high highs and I can
motivate someone I can get them to do
crazy [__] that typically those people
it's almost like a comedian they're
often if they're great on stage that
means they're probably sad a lot of
times or they get like down or like for
in my case I'm like this is gonna fail
this sucks and so I always look for
someone who's like pretty stable and
they're a rock who can like sustain like
a pretty even pace and they I can
motivate them to get excited but they
don't get down too easily I also look
for people who love you one at a time
let's go let's go one for one you you
say one trait I say one trait so for me
it's it's very very similar to what you
just described in yourself and it is
that that fire that sense of urgency and
that energy
I think most people out there just in
general a lot of people they they
they're like they're in slow motion they
walk slow they think slow they talk slow
they make decisions slow they're just
kind of lollygagging through life
they go into work they clock in at 9 00
a.m they do the bare minimum all day to
get paid next Friday and not get fired
and then they clock out and they go home
and drink a couple beers they're not
that excited about Hobbies they're not
that excited about much at all
which is fine yeah it's fine I just
don't wanna and you need those people a
lot of times
yeah which is fine those people are fine
and they serve a purpose
but then you get those people that have
that energy
you get those people that have that okay
I'm gonna get out of bed today and I'm
gonna attack this thing and we're gonna
make decisions fast we're gonna move
fast we're gonna talk fast we're gonna
take action fast and we're gonna get
[__] done and those people when you
bring them in
they can do all the other things on this
list I think everything else on my list
and your list feeds from hey we are
going to get stuff done quick when I
started my very first company it was a
moving company to pick up and delivery
storage for students
um we bought a cargo van on Craigslist
for three thousand dollars and we drove
it back to the track house this is kind
of a good example of the different the
way that people think about business and
opportunity
we were jacked up me and my business
partner we were all excited about the
idea of starting a company and going out
and trying to make some money we drove
this van back and we're like we're gonna
start doing pickup and delivery storage
for students and some of our buddies
they're sitting around we're sitting
around the track house playing beer pong
and they're like you guys are freaking
crazy what is exciting what do you know
about that what beer pong
no what do you what do you know about
moving like you know like who you're not
qualified yeah they're just like why is
that exciting you're gonna go what we're
gonna go have fun this weekend you're
gonna go around and sweat and pick up
boxes for 30 bucks a piece like that
does not sound fun to me I am I have
zero energy and zero excitement around
that and they would have quit or given
up in a week or two whereas we were
energetic we're excited we got after it
and we were able to convince some other
people to come along and you know that
was
yeah that's that's the whole thing
there's this great there's this great
book Robert you know Robert Green the
author Robert Greene he wrote that book
40 Laws of Power he has another book
that was way less popular called the
50th law and it's really weird because
he wrote it about 50 Cent and it's
actually a great book you know I know it
sounds weird but uh because he Robert
Greene he's into like a philosophy and
all this all this stuff but he talks
about like rappers and he loves hip-hop
culture and he uh and he's like 50 Cent
is really good at this because he has
done a good job Reinventing himself a
bunch of times he's uh changed his image
a bunch of times whatever and he said
the key to 50s uh success was his sense
of urgency and if you don't have a sense
of urgency in everything that you do it
it ruins everything and he doesn't just
talk about business people he talks
about poets he talks about people who
discover
um who invent different medicines like
you know poets writers whatever it's
always about anything doing anything
doing anything that makes your life
better is uncomfortable
going out and meeting somebody taking a
chance trying to get that really hot
girl in the bar to go on a date with you
it's all super uncomfortable and it's
very very easy to just be passive oh I
don't necessarily have the energy to do
that I'm a step back I used I used to
have a rule when I saw this is how I met
my wife when I saw a cute girl who I
want to talk to the I could only give
myself five seconds after seeing her
before I spoke to her
urgency baby girl it was the five second
rule because if you don't talk to them
within a couple seconds you're never
going to do it and the longer you wait
the harder it gets and so I was with the
five second rule
um I have a couple more on my list you
want me to go again or do you want to do
your second one yeah go go one more okay
so I think this one feeds into the next
one which is when you're starting a
company and people ask me a lot after
our last episode where I spoke about the
four or five companies that I'm starting
Nick how do you have time to do this how
are you doing it yourself and the answer
is I'm not I'm going and I'm tracking
down people who are really good and I
want you to Riff on this two Sam because
you're a master of bringing people
together
and I have this theory about recruiting
employees or Partners or people in your
early company which Step One is always
you know the website getting your click
funnels getting your copy writing down
getting your service put together but
then it's attracting people that's all
it is as an entrepreneur all you're
doing is attracting people I have a
theory about this so 10 of people are in
career Nirvana meaning they love their
job they're perfectly motivated and they
are under no circumstance are they going
to go and do something else
another 10 of people are literally
actively looking for something else
either they're unemployed or they really
hate their job and they are very open
and they're actively looking for jobs
these are the people that are looking on
job boards posting around you know for
anything that might be another
opportunity for them and there's 80
percent of people that are in the middle
eight out of ten people have
somewhere in the middle they like their
job but they're open to other things or
they could be open to other things but
they're not going to go on Monster or on
indeed or on LinkedIn and actually apply
for jobs
which typically is the those are the
winners those are the winners I've every
10 extra that I've ever hired and I've
been lucky enough to bring a lot of
10xers in into what I try to do and
again it's kind of because of my
Charisma and my sales ability and me
really going out and putting myself out
there and putting my sales hat on like
I'm literally turning into a Salesman
I'm going to try to attract talent to
come along on my mission
every single 10xer that I've gotten
involved Falls in that category they
were previously employed they had a job
they didn't hate and they had a boss
that really didn't want to let them go
and my entire career has been built upon
going and finding those people tracking
them down identifying them and
convincing them to leave that
opportunity and come along with me
how do you convince him
it's it's sales it's literally I'm I'm
selling them on my mission we can talk
about which looks like what sales is
another thing but I'm trying to make it
I'm trying to tell them how they can win
better than what they're winning right
now with me I can either make them more
money they can have a better quality of
life we can do something more fun I got
to get them to buy into my vision
I gotta be charismatic and and convince
them that they need to stop what they're
doing they need to make a big life
change which is a career is a huge
change to make and they gotta drop it
and come with me and you do the same
thing Sam yeah usually what I do is
I'll like I'll find someone interesting
and I I just chat them up and I go I'll
be like I usually like to flatter people
so I say you're amazing what's your
story
and they'll just gush and tell you their
story and I act interested because I am
interested and then
um usually I'm like where do you want to
be in a handful of years what do you
want to do and if they tell me something
where I'm like oh I could help you get
there sometimes I can't sometimes it's
like I I can't help you get there but um
if they if I can then I tailor my pitch
around helping them get there and I'll
say something like would you like to
come join me for a handful of years and
I bet you we could set you up nicely to
get you to where you want to go and I
tailor my pitch all about them and how
I'm going to help them achieve their
goals and typically what I do
I've said this a bunch of times which is
the world wants people to be vanilla
they want you to fit into a very uh safe
box and I think a lot of people dread
that even though they are living that
life and so I tend to go the excitement
and fun angle because a lot of the times
I'm not necessarily building the next
SpaceX like if you're like work at Nasa
there is some big Vision which is like
we're putting someone on the moon or if
you look at work at some type of company
that's like creating a life-saving drug
I'm like we're gonna save lives but I
don't really do stuff like that I just
do awesome stuff like fun stuff and so I
typically lean into excitement where
it's like look we're gonna build this
pirate ship together and you're gonna be
leading it or you're going to be
contributing it in a way where we're
going to agree on the rules but you
could as long as you play Within those
rules you could do whatever you want and
so that's typically how I pitch
I love it and when I'm making a key
higher I do the exact same thing I call
it like the motivational interview if
I'm hiring somebody who's a little bit
higher level I'm making an investment
they're making a big change I need them
to do some pretty important stuff I'll
sit there in the interview and I'll be
like Sam
we're talking about this company right
now but let's pretend that we're five
years in the future you and I are
sitting right here we're in this office
in five years
and you walk into this office and you
are gushing you're excited you're like
Nick things are going freaking awesome
tell me what is going on tell me how
much money you're making
tell me how big your team is tell me if
you're working from home how much you're
working tell me what kind of projects
you're working on and then I just shut
up and I let them talk and I get to hear
what makes them tick and where they want
to go and if my company
can't put that together sometimes it's
it's a it's a really valuable tool
because a lot of times 30 40 of time
I'll be like wow
um I can't deliver on this my company
can't deliver on this yeah but then
other times I'll be like okay I just it
just gives you a look in how these
people tick you know what I mean
yeah yeah and you got to tailor it so
the the third thing or the second thing
that we won't talk about because we
already did is speed I look for Speed
um and that's quite hard to find most
people aren't fast
um my my current partner Joe Joe Spicer
he's the only person I've worked with
that I'm like Joe you're going fast man
it's hard for me to keep up so I I look
for Speed a lot but the third thing is
follow through so people who actually
act and I find that to be probably the
hardest thing to find
um and I actually a lot of things are
trainable I don't think that that I
think you either you you is or you ain't
when it comes to following through and
like actually doing stuff and what I
tend to do is I like to look at people
who have products or projects that are
live so someone will be like where this
one lady reply to one of our tweets and
she's like I sold a hundred thousand
dollars worth of Taylor Swift t-shirts
and I'm like okay that's that's all I
need to know you do stuff or maybe they
have a blog or maybe they tweet or maybe
they have a YouTube channel or maybe
they
um have some type of hobby that involves
like taking action and I always look for
those things it could be like I or I
organize clubs in college just anything
where I see like all right you follow
through you say you're gonna do
something and you do it I look for that
a lot and you also you you've told me
this in the group chat is that you will
give them a small job and that knocks
off if somebody's interested in joining
Sam par the sampar ride and getting
involved in one of your companies one of
these things you're going to give them
something to do and that'll knock off 80
of the people and because they're not
going to follow us through they're not
going to fall through I think the I got
a good story web run the guy that I
found to start this front-end web
development landing page company his
name's Will Wallace he's a coder he
lives in Atlanta one of the most
brilliant dudes I know and when I saw
him I was like will
I need I need I need a favor and I was
testing him you didn't know what I said
I need a favor I need a landing page and
I need something to form up on my
website I need it like right away and
then boom the next morning I woke up and
it was there and it was freaking awesome
and he just moved so fast just got stuff
done so quickly that speed and sense of
urgency that you're talking about if you
can find a way to get a look into their
mind and it goes back to like Hey we're
looking to assemble a group of people as
an entrepreneur we're looking to
assemble a group people
how do you know who those 10xers are how
do you know who those 10xers are
getting a look into their mind with some
of these ways that we're talking about
like you're saying give them something
to do give them something to follow
through on like look at them
often I tell them I get pitched like
five times a day you probably do two
people want to make short clips for me
yep and I almost ignore all of them but
every once in a while I'll be like um
all right make me a video then and I'll
tell them I won't I go I'm not even
gonna post it so don't worry about free
work like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
profit off your work make me a video
then
um and we used to do this all the time
people would apply to the hustle for
writing writing I go okay write
tomorrow's email
and uh
yeah like I would every once in a while
I would get a 1200 word thing the next
day I go all right sick we'll talk what
you're looking for is a look into the
mind of these people to figure out if
they're a 10xer so if you're going out
and you're trying to build these teams
you can shoot from the hip you can put
bring somebody in from an interview and
then you can make the hire or you can
try to get a preview try to get a
preview another thing that I look for on
my list and these two blend together I'm
gonna talk about both these things
clear and concise communication
so many people you'll have a
conversation and you'll listen to them
for 60 seconds 90 seconds and you'll be
like what the hell is this person even
talking about get to the point whereas
you have Nick Huber on on your podcast I
can say exactly what I've done and where
I've been and how many storage
facilities I have and I've given you
three or four things to bite off on the
first 28 seconds that I've been on the
show because I'm a very clear and
concise Communicator so I look for that
I listen to that when I'm talking to
other business people hey you're trying
to tell me a story you're trying to get
a point across how quick how clear and
how concise can you do it and the
ability to get points out how would you
feel verse 30 is just mind-blowing
how would you feel if someone referred
to themselves in the third person in an
interview like you just did that's a
that's a that's a I'm out dog that's an
I'm out dog right away
[Laughter]
everybody wants to hear about the social
justice Warrior tweet that I had a
couple days ago but yeah I mean there's
a lot of red flags too that are instant
Cuts you're just looking for red flags
that's what you're doing somebody refers
to themselves as Nick Huber in the third
person cut out
dude and the last thing that I have
that's related is and this is hard to
figure out a little bit but I look for
Taste and intelligence Intelligence
being like just like I always say oh my
does your oven burn hot like are you
just smart or um and can you like do you
have like emotional intelligence but
also
um taste so I like to ask people what
content they consume I'd be like you
like to read what do you read yeah um
yeah I'm like where do you where do you
get your news uh or if they're like I'm
like seriously just tell me like who do
you follow on Instagram or what
subreddits do you like to read anything
I just want to know a little bit about
your taste I've noticed that and that's
when somebody puts you on the spot like
that that's really tough because what
they want to do is please Sam they want
to say what you want to hear but they
don't know it's like somebody saying hey
what's your political affiliation tell
me who you voted for I'm gonna be like
oh oh I don't know who did you vote for
I voted for them
no and I don't care what they read I'm
just like explain to me why it's
exciting because if you're not excited
about what you consume every day then
you're boring and I don't want to be
around you and you and and but I also
want to know what their taste is because
I'll hire certain people and they like
write in a certain way that's maybe too
corporate or uh like my brain is fun and
so like if there's not fun or they don't
get that I'm like this is just it's a
bad culture fit that we're not going to
blend well so I look for taste a lot and
I ask them what they consume or
I do this thing called the bottom fourth
of the resume so at the very bottom of
people's resume is like where they put
like the Hobbies or like what they did
in college and they'll say like I
studied philosophy
I'm like all right cool I mean I don't
really care about philosophy but I'm
like what was your favorite class and if
they say oh I'm not sure I'm like oh
you're out but if they like if they say
like you know well this philosophy class
which I don't even know about I'll just
be like well why and if they can
entertain me and convince me that it was
interesting I'm like all right cool
you're all right uh so I look for taste
a lot on the bottom fourth of the of the
resume
is wrong every freaking time
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
I have a theory that uh you can get paid
really really well and you can earn a
great living if you're good at your job
if you're good at your job you're worth
you're worth a heck of a lot to a lot of
companies what do you Albertson
congratulations on that great Theory
yeah no if now this is the theory this
is the big this is the big part if you
can make other people good at their jobs
not just you good at your job but if you
can lead other people and set them up
for success and make other people good
at their job
you are the 10xer you're the 10xer so
I'm going to look for delegators who can
do that who can lead other people and
grow the business Beyond because look if
I hire somebody and I'm their direct
report but they can't be the direct
report of other people they're going to
be a bottleneck I'm going to be
bottleneck they're not going to help me
grow the company
now the two things that I think are
related to that that are kind of
counterintuitive number one is
copywriting they're a really good
copywriter I think that's directly
correlated to be able being able to
delegate and lead other people because
if you can write it really and concisely
if you can write like clearly and
concisely the way people can understand
it you can lead others you can give
directions you can be on slack text
email the way that we run our businesses
is through the written word
very luckily I can see how people write
I can see it because they're dming me
I'm reading their tweets I get to look
into how they write and I think I took
your
your email course I want to talk about
this because I took this nine months ago
or so blew my mind it made me a better
copywriter and now I have it
yeah so Sam has a course where for 10
days in a row he's going to send 10
weeks in a row is it days in a row is it
once a week
that one day uh one a day for 10 days
one a day for two days so two weeks you
send an email that teaches people how to
do copywriting and I did it I got the
email the first day and I spent my wife
comes in and I got a notebook full of
copy written down she's like what the
hell are you doing and I was like well
Sam told me it's gonna work just trust
me so 10 days I write and I copy these
Styles and I start to learn how clear
and concise communication and hooks and
throw away all the words that don't
matter where's that located again by the
way copy copy that.com copythat.com so
the word copy and then that yeah 150
bucks or something and it's been worth I
would you know 50 Grand at it to my
career easy the best do you know why
that works I I tried to explain it in
that in the thing it's called copywork
and it's how I learned how to write and
it was like this way that they used to
teach kids how to write uh and in the
1930s and 40s I think there was like a
change in the public schools and this
thing got thrown to the side but
um it's called copywork and like if like
Ben Franklin used to write this way um
100 Thompson uh he like said this is how
he write Judd Apatow the director and
what they would do is they would find
like scripts or like if you're Judd
Apatow you would find like a funny
script that you want to emulate or if
you're Hunter S Thompson you would find
you'd do like Catcher in the Rye or some
book that you like because when you copy
it by hand you start seeing the patterns
and the uh the texture of something the
same way where if you want to learn how
to play guitar you're not going to like
get the guitar in day one and write a
song You're Gonna like play Jingle Bells
and then you're gonna like move to happy
birthday and then eventually you're
gonna move to like rock and roll and
then maybe blues and then you're like oh
this riff from Guns and Roses it kind of
reminds me of this riff from the blues
if I'm gonna like I'll match that with
this and I'll steal this from here and
then boom I've got my own piece of art
and that's why it's really good it and
there's actually science behind it where
it like it imprints into your brain and
you learn the flow of certain things
so if you could get good at writing and
getting your ideas across and also
selling other people because people
think delegating is just telling people
what to do no you have to make them want
to do it and it's sales life is sales so
it's it's a beautiful resource do you
have a few more or no yeah I want to
tweet so I want to go through
how I think about sales because I think
this is really important because life is
sales and as an entrepreneur you're
selling to customers you're selling to
investors and and partners and you're
selling to your employees just like I
said you got to go find these people who
have jobs and you got to sell your idea
and your vision on them so I want to
give you kind of a breakdown on how I
think about sales and how I kind of flip
the script and I can give you kind of an
example of that
the old school way to sell is
you're going to be pushy you're going to
ask directly you're going to speak the
language you're going to prove that
you're an expert and then you're going
to talk about all the benefits and all
the great things and then you're going
to hand them a clipboard and ask for
their signature
I think that that way is a terrible way
to actually sell people in today's world
of so many options so my way to do it is
I speak the language briefly and prove
that I'm a professional without being
braggadocious or bragging on me or the
proc or or the product that I'm trying
to sell
then what I do is I dive right into
talking about the downsides
why I'm worried about it why the deal
might not work all the things that we
need to stress about
and then I ask them given those
downsides why they still want to do the
deal or why they still want to work with
me or why I still want to work for my
company
and then I shut up and I let them it
kind of flips the script to where they I
do that all the time they become the
salesperson
so like Sam you're about to start
working for me as you know you want to
come to work for Nick really bad and
we're going to start this company
together I'll say dude this is an agency
business it's really hard it might take
six months before we make any money at
all we might be stuck in it worst case
scenario we're going to waste a year of
our life
why do you want to come join me
another really a great example of this
is for my investors and my real estate
deals
they're good they get on a call with me
and they expect me to just sit there and
regurgitate all the great things about
storage all the great things about real
estate Investments the tax benefits why
I'm such a good operator all that stuff
I don't do any of that I get on a call
with somebody a zoom call with somebody
and they already know me they're already
on a call they're already interested
investing in storage
so I talk about all the downsides I'll
say look Sam
Let's do an example here you give me
this 50 Grand you're gonna invest with
me and let's say interest rates Spike
the economy tanks people don't use
storage as much and all of a sudden this
deal is worth 20 or 30 percent less than
what it was and instead of giving you an
eight percent cash on cash return I'm
gonna give you a two percent cash on
cash return now it's my job to make sure
we don't lose the properties I'm gonna
do this this and this to think about
risk but why do you want to invest in
storage boom flip the script flip the
script and the person will say well Nick
it seems like you've thought a lot about
these risks like you're worried about
this stuff I don't have to worry about
this stuff I don't need cash flow off of
this it's a long-term investment all the
other reasons why you know it might work
that way
when you're starting these new things
how much do you fund them with uh
recruit jet we put uh
uh 50 Grand in the bank account web run
we put 10 grand in the bank account uh
blue key Capital we're gonna put 50
Grand in the bank account
did I tell you about Kevin right you
know that is you're coming I'm doing
what he does
Kevin Ryan I've talked to him about him
a bunch on this pod he's kind of my hero
um he started he was the CEO of
doubleclick which eventually sold to
Google for multiple billions and it
became AdWords or whatever AdWords or I
forget the AdSense I think AdSense one
of those like the the way Google makes
all the money so it's like the best
acquisition ever
he was uh like employee 20 there and
then he took over as CEO sold the
company for multiple billions and then
he went and started um he took like his
whatever he made 10 million dollars and
this other guy who worked at doubleclick
named Dwight and they go we're gonna
start this thing called silicon alley so
they're based in New York so it was like
their take on Silicon Valley and they
invested he goes we would put our whole
shtick was we're gonna invest 300 000
into a handful of interesting ideas we
have and we'll try to find someone to
partner and we'll try to make them big
and we want big outcomes and with this
method he started uh guilt you know like
the women's fashion clothing company it
it didn't work out but it got to like
hundreds of millions of Revenue he
started Business Insider which had a 600
million dollar exit he started mongodb
which is a publicly traded database
company at I don't know it's ranges
between 20 and 30 billion on on the mark
uh market cap uh what else did he start
he started um Zola which is like the
wedding registry business he started uh
like maybe three other things that are
big and he goes I give each company six
months and 300 or 400 000 something like
that and you know 300K is kind of a lot
I mean it's definitely a lot of money
but it's not that much money for how
much value he creates and he gives it
300K in six months and that's how long
it takes him to like figure out if an
idea is going to be uh worth it it all
depends on the opportunity I mean some
of these the the guy that we're
partnering with on recruitjet
me and saho and Marshall from support
Shepherd are starting a company called
recruit jet it's a head hunt Us Talent
this exact way like Hey we're gonna go
into that 80 of people we're going to
find them for companies the guy that's
our head recruiter he's been a recruiter
for 15 years he's done work for me he's
a complete badass he's not going to
leave his job he's not going to leave
his job until we get our first contract
signed like so we don't have any
expenses yet
on the other side of the table I'm
trying to start a debt brokerage firm
meaning we're going to be the middleman
that finds and secures debt for Giant
commercial real estate projects we're
going to go to all the banks we're going
to shop them we're gonna put the
packages together and close the loans
I'm right now on the road trying to
attract a partner in that business I
have somebody in mind I'm gonna have to
Shell out a lot of money because this
guy makes 450 grand for a bank right now
he's our best loan officer he's a 10x or
he's a killer I'm gonna have to make him
an offer where it's a little bit less
Equity less of a percentage of sales but
I'm going to guarantee him 200 Grand a
year for two years me personally off my
personal checkout hey this is I'm gonna
sign a contract with you because I
already know how he thinks I already
know he's a 10xer I know he's incredible
he's done incredible things for our
company when it comes to sourcing debt
come to work for blue key capital
I'm gonna guarantee you I'm gonna
promise you two years of Runway at 200
Grand a year
but are you gonna put any additional
capital
yeah we'll have to we need to hire some
additional people but for the most part
it'll be website landing page customer
dot IO automatic replies to emails you
know just be building the infrastructure
that I'm so good at doing for all these
other companies it will because you're
actually going to do it you're going to
write all the copy you're going to set
up the email
um web run I'm gonna have web run do
that
um and then I'm going to create a a
a Twitter account
make the follow account and then I do a
a software called uh bird flow that has
an automatic DM so every time yep you
told me about it every time somebody
follows the account they get a DM and
they'll say hey if you're placing any
debt on any big projects or you're
buying something you need help with
banks
um give us a call and we'll just drive
leads that way so it'll be does that
does this person have a family what's
that does this person have a family yeah
he's got a 12 year old and a
nine-year-old and his wife doesn't freak
you out
it's very it's very
freaky yeah it's it's it drives pretty
significant insecurity yeah I mean even
will even will at rev run he had to
leave a job where he's making 400 Grand
to start an agency with me so like
selling these people like identifying
the 10xers and selling them on coming to
join the Nick Huber mission
like that's that's what it all is like
that's that's the hardest part of this
stuff the first family person that I
hired the person that had a family they
had children
I remember thinking like that when we
hired them I was like I have a family I
was like I now have a family you know I
was only 26 and I was like [__] feels
like I have a child and it's it
shouldn't actually feel that way maybe
but in a way it kind of should where I'm
like oh [__] like I have like if this is
no longer just necessarily about me this
is about like all these other people and
stakeholders involved and I remember
freaking out I was very nerve-wracking
the stakes go up and it definitely have
some times where I'll wake up at night
and I'll be like what the hell am I
doing like am I really thinking we can
drive enough business to support this
person and I'm convincing them to leave
their job and their livelihood they make
450 Grand a year right now I'm I'm
insane
dude it's scary what about um what did
you you message something you tweeted
something out the other day that got you
got a lot of flack for what did you what
did you say I'll just read the Tweet
because it's funny so
um we talk about
social justice Warriors a lot inside of
our group chat
um how many what what would you what's a
social justice Warrior so a social
justice Warrior is anybody it can be a
supreme leftist or it can be a Trumper
it can be somebody who is out on a
mission to change the way that a certain
group of people is totally mistreated
whether it be people who want to carry
guns or whether it be minorities whether
it be uh you know people who feel a
certain way from a certain place they're
just out on a mission to go to war with
culture to make it better for a certain
group of people that's a social justice
warrior in my opinion am I is that a
correct correct definition that's
significantly more positive than how I
use it a social justice Warrior to me is
someone who like is very close-minded
very outspoken and will not
be well balanced or open-minded to new
ideas and new facts or and who will
automatically dislike you because you do
believe in something regardless if
you're like for example let's say you're
this is a controversial one but Pro or
anti-abortion it doesn't matter which
side you fall on yep
you could probably have a conversation
with either side a lot of people can be
like well I disagree with you on that
but I understand your perspective and I
don't hate you for it you just have
different opinions than I do whereas the
social justice Warrior is like well
you're wrong regardless of how you feel
yep that's a you you put it exactly
right so I made this tweet the worst
thing you can do as an entrepreneur is
hire a social justice Warrior
people who are very radical politically
are way more likely to sue you or your
business upset your customers and upset
your team members either side of the
aisle I said luckily politics is not a
protected class so I'm allowed to view
somebody's social media
and then I said these folks bash people
that they don't know on Twitter and
social media constantly
um and I and I said you don't think
they'll take to a public forum to bash
you and your company when you fire them
for missing work to attend the eighth
Rally or March of the year
and so what do people say to that
no I didn't get any hate did you oh yeah
oh yeah the people who it's got 64 quote
tweets right now
um this guy says bro just say that you
don't hire black people it's way easier
um like people are just really calling
me a racist and calling me a lot of
really mean things which I'm not at all
I'm I'm I am trying to I'm trying to
weed out people who are close-minded
because if you're radically politically
left or radically politically right
that just tells me that you're not
balanced because nobody that I know is
super radical politically just a giant
waste of time and energy so I just think
it's a good practice if you're a
business owner look at the way people
spend their time where are they if they
told you they were in Reddit anti-work
when you asked them that question
earlier like what content are you
consuming oh I'm in Reddit anti-work
uh okay out well I and it but they could
make a good argument as to why they
enjoy it so for example I like reading
have you seen this subreddit called the
what's the one where people have
multiple jobs oh yeah yeah that is that
is fascinating entertainment value is
another thing it's these people who get
multiple jobs like sometimes three or
four jobs and though and I've known a
couple people who have done this it's
called overemployed it's called
overemployed it's a pretty funny name
and like I've known dude I've known
people who have done this so they get a
job at Facebook and Google and so
they'll and they call it J1 and J2 and
so they'll post like advice like hey so
my J1 has me working from like I can get
it done from like eight to ten a.m and
then J2 is like noon to three how do you
people like uh get your manager to only
put meetings for J1 in the AM or
something like that and it's crazy and
I've known a guy who had a job at
Facebook and Google 250 000 or something
like crazy for each job so and they'll
say like so total income is 600 000
that's broken up with J1 at 200 000 J2
at 300 000 and they'll like say this
it's hilarious and I read it all the
time because I'm like like well
I'm pretty sure I'm against that because
that's unethical it's not illegal but I
wouldn't like that some did it to me but
then I'm like
but is that wrong and so anyway I like
to like read that to like just explore
new ideas and it's also just hilarious
so someone told me they read anti-work
or overemployed I'd be like okay why
tell me what do you learn uh it goes
really it goes really deep as I'm diving
into the stuff on recruitjet and
learning how recruiting companies work
and I've talked to probably 15
Recruiters in the past month and just
asked them you know what about there are
people who will literally show up to an
interview like this an interview like
this and their mouth is moving but
somebody else is talking to them and
it's the people who are no way no way
yes tell me tell me about that so what
happens
if you're so you're a recruiter somebody
hires you to go place a tech position
you're a technical recruiter you're
going to find somebody to work for
Google for 250 Grand a year you're going
to go in and you're going to sort
through Linkedin you're going to bring
in all these applicants and you got to
try to find a way to scan out a third of
the applicants a third of these people
are trying to get more than one job
being a being a software developer and
you literally can talk to them on the
phone and that can't do it because then
they can wire in somebody else to talk
if you and that's why they do that
that's why they do video is for that
reason they have to do video I should
have asked the guy a lot more questions
about it if you're following me and Sam
and you're listening to this and you
obviously know about this occurrence
tweet us because I want to know more
about this as well but he told me that
you're on a zoom call with somebody and
it's blurry and and their voice is not
really the one talking and it's people
who are trying to get more than one
freaking job
crazy that's ridiculous that's that's
that's kind of amazing and like there's
some way you got to look at from a like
that's sleazy don't do that but also
you're like
that's pretty amazing you know it's like
a lot of my
my sleazy friends in high school they
would like pay someone to take the ACT
form
and I remember thinking like I don't
know man that's pretty that's almost as
impressive it's actually doing a good
job
you know what I mean I'm like I don't
want to work with you but like kinda I
do it's like if you can use that for
good you see so many criminals get
caught doing all this crazy stuff and
you just think that if they put that
energy towards something productive how
rich they could get
we had um
we had this guy named Michael Harris
Michael Harris founded Death Row Records
you know death row they like created
Tupac Dr Dre NWA like they basically
invented like modern hip-hop or they
invented like gangster marketing they
were the marketing machine behind those
guys right yeah and so Michael Harris
partnered with Suge Knight and Michael
Harris did it from prison he was serving
um 25 to life he got in trouble for
attempted murder which eventually he got
exonerated by Trump two years ago and he
got let out but he served 30 years
partially on death row and the other
charge that he was convicted of that I
think he I I he admitted to doing was he
was selling
at times two million dollars a day of
cocaine of crack and he was talking
about it and he was like once I started
getting all that money coming in I
started realizing like I also need to go
legit and do things the right way and so
we started buying real estate and he
started doing all this other stuff and
he was like I was killing it in the drug
game but like I killed it even harder
like just doing the legal stuff like I
you know he's like I had the cash flow
from it so like I I definitely profited
off of it but he bought buildings he
started a limo company he um eventually
death row was bringing in like north of
100 million in Revenue because CDs at
the time were 19 and it was like a
dollar to make a CD and he was like we
killed it the right way but I did all
this bad stuff so I had to pay the price
I think he was like it's such a good
example that business is simply a
flywheel around these things that we've
spoke about in this episode
if you can get these things right
attracting people leading people
managing people delegating writing
it can work in any business once you
learn these skills I could put Sam par
and I could take him and I could drop
him in a grocery store chain and I
guarantee you you would Thrive I
guarantee you you could succeed just
because of the way that you think about
business the way that you can lead
people and the decisions that you would
make so
um I feel strongly that once you get the
flywheel going and once you push
yourself and once you start to learn
some of these things you can you can
crush it
you you're doing something that I hate
doing
and I advise most people not to do it
but there's many examples of people
doing it successfully of which you're
one of them which is doing multiple
things at once in most cases I think
doing multiple things at once is a
horrible idea I think we saw uh the few
times it does work is when there's like
a Ryan Reynolds you see Ryan Reynolds uh
sold mint Mobile today for like 1.5
billion or two bill whatever it was and
then like last year he sold what was his
liquor his liquor or Avion or something
like that he sold that for hundreds of
millions and you know I don't have any
idea but it says like Ryan Reynolds
sells his telephone company and I'm like
probably has nothing to do with it he
just does the commercials maybe he has
something to do with it I have no idea
and I have no idea it says like Ryan
Reynolds his his Telecom company got
sold maybe he only owns like three
points I have no idea but in that case
someone like him he does have multiple
things
when it's you
who you are doing a lot of the work and
you're not you're famous or you're a big
deal but you're not like everyone in
America knows who you are I think that
it's scary and it's challenging why are
you doing more than one thing versus
just one thing
I'm I'm pushing myself I don't know if I
can do it there's a lot of anxiety
around it and some of these things will
fail I mean look it's five companies
that we've started in the past year
um what will the collective revenue of
those be do you think in 2024 okay so
you want me to make a prediction and
then we can come back on and test it
actually so
I think Ari kosteg will be doing 500
Grand a month or or so anybody in 12
months
um in the year 2024 at the end of 2024
we'll look back on the year and I think
it'll do 2.5 million ebitdon probably so
okay
um
webron I think on what Top Line
okay
30 margins so whatever that math is
getting close to 10 million in sales
yeah yeah I think Ari Costa will be
really big in the year 2024 so 18 months
from now like trailing
um Titan risk the commercial risk
property insurance company I think that
one will do
three million in sales at a 50 50 margin
probably for insurance brokerage okay
um webron I think will be doing
200 Grand a month
uh if Revenue so maybe 70 to 100 Grand a
month of profit
um recruit jet I think will be a big
company I think recruitjet will be 5
million of Revenue and three million of
ebitda
okay so collectively you're you're in
the Six Million profit range or
something like that seven million I
forget yeah what would blue key Capital
blue key Capital could be the big one
the debt the debt brokerage company for
Real Estate firms that one could be
doing
again five another five to ten million
of Revenue as well pretty good margins
the small team
and would you so uh 2.5 million for cost
sake what would that be valued at could
it be as high as 10 times profit no I
don't think so cost sag is uh
politically dependent you know if if
bonus depreciation rules go up and down
it changes the demand for costs eggs
right so I think three to four times
ebitda would probably be the value of
that company wouldn't be worth selling
so the cash flow is awesome the
multiples are [__] everything that I've
ever started typically the cash flow is
only okay but the multiples are really
really good this is this is one of our
20 times profit Yep this is what I can't
stand I I tried to convince a kid to
come with me to do a web development
agency and I failed my sales pitch
failed he didn't join me and he kept
saying there's no Enterprise Value he
kept saying there's no EV in web
development
and my entire thesis is screw EV
will come
I want to be making money every single
month in cash flow every single year
that's the goal and if we can do that
good things will happen over time and
we'll see which one of these companies
really takes off
but to play devil's advocate here when I
was first starting the hustle I was
doing the math
and I was like wherever I want to be by
the age of 30 so in five years after
starting or four years after starting
you have to make a ton of profit like
selling a company if you can get 10 or
15 times earnings or three or four times
Revenue that's a huge that's a huge
number and for a lot of businesses it's
not impossible to get that you know you
need some type of recurring Revenue in a
really big market and fast growth
but like to make like
20 to 50 million dollars or
significantly higher my argument is it's
way easier to get there by selling
selling to get capital gains there's a
lot of people who have done it
like Andrew Wilkinson's company is just
like killing it and so he's doing it
through cash flow
um but if you like do the math Val yeah
my friend Val is doing it but he also
sold the company he sold the company uh
he sold two of them for tens of millions
of dollars
I my opinion is
and there's
there's so many examples where I'm wrong
but in most cases I think you it's
significantly easier to sell something
than it is to earn through income that's
my problem Sam is I've never sold I
haven't sold a company right now I've
never I've never sold something to
create a massive liquidity event
so I don't want you yeah I think I would
um the I mean unless you work in finance
maybe like in your one of your company
two of your companies are financially
related unless you work in finance I
think it's hard to get a significant
amount of income but like I don't know
like Donald Trump claims to have done it
like a bunch of people have claimed to
have done it through through real estate
and finance but I think it's hard
through a product a product based
company
if you can wait it out I mean time is on
your side you know what I mean if you if
you're okay living I look I live in a I
live in a house that I bought for 290
000 I drive a truck that's worth about
12 grand
um like if I can just
not buy a private plane or a four
million dollar house I don't have to
sell anything and I think time will
really help me so I'm on the I'm on the
train how do you
but how are you not like like you know
desire is also like evil you know when
it comes to this stuff like when you
want [__] you suffer and so like I know
a lot of people that are really wealthy
and every once in a while I fall into
this trap where I'm like
five years ago if I knew if if I
my my five you know my 25 year old if
they knew where I was today they'd be
like oh you're fine and then I get to
where I am now and I'm like oh but
there's another step or what about a 10
or 20 million dollar home or what about
uh having a warehouse full of cars or
what about doing this or that or owning
a sports team like okay you need more
you don't desire things or a 50 000
watch or something of course I do man of
course I do I really want an airplane I
really want a pc12 and that's my goal is
to have how much is that it's a five
million dollar airplane
and
we could go from here to La without
stopping for gas
um
that's a goal of mine but but why own it
instead of I knew a guy I knew a guy who
bought a Jet for 16 million dollars
during the pandemic when he had just
sold the company for 100 million bucks
he owned it for six months and he was
like what the hell am I doing with this
and he ended up selling it for 20
million he goes I made a profit on it
which was lucky but it was looking like
a horrible Finance financial decision
because I had to spend all this money to
store it it was like it was the
stupidest thing ever yeah it's straight
overhead for sure straight overhead but
I need to I live my family lives seven
hours from here and driving with my
family is something we're only going to
do once a year so I can't get back to
see my dad and my mom and my grandfather
who's only got a couple years left
without easy access to get back so it'd
be really nice to have an airplane but
yeah I'm I'm not going to do it like I
decided with my wife we're gonna wait
because I just want to show my kids that
I'm not just going to go out and buy
everything I want and I'm gonna suffer a
little bit and that's okay and you know
delayed gratification keeps me humble
too and but it's tough I battle with it
every day man I mean it's really easy
but you want stuff what what's your
what's your dream number
like as far as personal net worth
yeah
if I'm making a million dollars a month
I think I can then do whatever I want
isn't that funny I but I bet you would
have thought that
10 years ago if you are where you are
now you could do whatever you want if
somebody would have told me five years
ago that when I retire I am where I am
right now I would have given him a
thumbs up and and said I'm happy please
make that happen
so dude the goal the goal post always
changes it's so it's so hard man and
it's easy for me to cry and say oh it's
tough but it it's like a
it's a tough thing to swallow as a man
when like all of a sudden you have
seven figures in your checking account
you have hundreds of thousands of
dollars a month that come your way and
you got to figure out what gets you out
of bed and how you're gonna not be an
[__] and how you're gonna raise good
kids and how and I don't know about you
but I get excited about hobbies and I'll
pick up Golf and I'll or I'll tennis or
pickleball or airplanes whatever and
I'll just get really really really into
it and then it's on to the next thing
it's on to the next thing on to the next
thing and I don't like that about myself
I wish that I was more disciplined long
term and
how do you feel about that
um
I'm very disciplined I think
uh compared
compared to a lot of people I think I
have a I'm fairly disciplined I think I
uh we spend anywhere from when we're in
Austin I spend fifteen thousand dollars
a month or so when I'm in New York I
spend a little bit more
but because I don't drink and go out
like Monday to Friday we don't go out at
night because it's a school night we say
we go it's a school night we're not
going out
um I live in a house that was is under a
million dollars or paid well under a
million dollars so which in Austin
um
um it's kind of hard to find that stuff
but um I think I'm pretty disciplined
long term but I do struggle with wanting
more and my wife is always like stop
wanting that like you're gonna drive
yourself crazy uh and so like I do
always want more stuff
um and I try to like like I want like
I want to buy just a huge Garage in
Brooklyn and just stash all types of
cars and motorcycles and then to have
like a Fantasy Factory and just open up
the garage door and just sit in front of
it and anyone who walks by and like
admires it I'll be like oh you want to
come in and look like I'll show you
around we could like play with it all
like I want that and that's gonna cost
20 million bucks maybe like I I and and
it's a pointless thing because when you
die you don't get any of it but uh uh
like high-end bourbon like how much is
that how fancy you think of bourbon
um the most expensive bottle was like 7
500 and this is going to make me you
paid for 7500 you bought a 7 500 does it
taste any different what's it do this is
me being vulnerable
I have zero life overhead like I could
cut my spending to five grand a month
and put my kids in daycare and pay for
my house payment which is twelve hundred
dollars so I've avoided like the big
expenses I've avoided the big big house
the plane the big cars whatever it is so
I splurge on some of the little things
that sound huge and obnoxious to some
people but aren't really that obnoxious
so I got some really nice bourbon some
bottles that are really special
and then I got him I'm looking at them
in my bar
and I send a text to like four of my
boys I'm like hey come over let's try
some bourbon
and nobody can come over they can't come
and hang out
they're all working
or they're out of town or whatever so
the next morning I got up and I just
looked at it I opened one of the nicer
bottles I poured a little bit myself and
I'm like
[__] none of this matters none of this
matters at all it is all about the
people and the people how they feel
about you whether or not they care about
you whether or not they respect you how
you can help them how you can help them
become better versions of themselves
so the stuff is really just a
distraction
it sounds cliche because everybody says
that but it hit me when I was looking at
that bourbon and I'm like my parents my
dad loves bourbon he's seven hours away
my brother's nine hours away he's not
here
Sam par doesn't drink alcohol he can't
come over with me
you know what I mean yeah does a 7 500
bottle taste any different than a 50
bottle I haven't opened it yet it's the
mikter's 20 year
does a thousand dollar bottle taste any
different you know I think it does
because it sounds ridiculous no it
doesn't Sam it doesn't it [__]
doesn't
it's just a Pokemon card it's an ego
thing man I'm a I'm a weak man who is
after the ego sometimes and I gotta stay
I just gotta remind myself of that it
doesn't matter does it
I bought like a decent car and that
makes me happier but besides that most
most items don't um what am I gonna do I
can invite somebody cool over there's a
couple pro golfers in town that I'm
friendly with and I keep saying like
come over and drink some of my nice
Bourbon and what am I going to be that
[__] guy who brings in this famous
person into my house and is like yeah
drink my awesome Bourbon and just
talking about how awesome that gets so
[__] dumb like I'm such an idiot
I don't think it's dumb where do you
where do you uh buy this from and you
you do cigars too those are yeah so
those are those are two of my hobbies
it's cigars and bourbon because I share
them both with my dad and golf can you
be any more of a stereotype
golly but my house is so weak like it's
literally sitting on the bourbon is
sitting on a 200 really shitty cabinet
that I got from Home Depot when I read
it in my basement but
um no a guy over in Carrollton Georgia
I'm his biggest customer and every year
he gets the releases and drives it over
to me and I give them an envelope full
of a lot of cash you got a guy dude I
love having Hobbies where you got a guy
that's the best that's the best one
um I appreciate you doing this we had a
good episode
um what anything you wanna you wanna
pimp out or promote
um a lot of people ask me where they
could invest with bolt storage and real
estate's really slow but you can go to
boltstorage.com investors if you're an
accredited investor and you want to get
storage exposure and also my newsletter
that I write every week I think a lot
about this stuff a lot of the stuff
we're talking about like what how many
subscribers do you have on that I'm up
to 42 000. I'm working it really hard
I'm adding like 600 a month it's kind of
kind of weak but uh I I write a lot
about a lot of this like what makes a
10x or how do you think about this stuff
how do you think about hiring management
like getting this these teams together
so if you go to if you go to my Twitter
at sweaty startup there's a little Link
in my bio and you can join my join my
newsletter all right we appreciate you
thanks for doing this
[Music]
foreign